quand le fantôme du titanic remontent à
la surface les techniciens français de
l'ifremer travaille actuellement depuis
le début du mois au renflouement d'une
partie du titanic 84 ans après le
naufrage de ce navire au large de saint
jean de terre neuve une opération d'un
coût d'environ 25 millions de francs
jean claude allègre objets figé au fond
de la mer tout hors du girou y est
dérisoire témoin d'un luxe désormais
enfouis par 4000 mètres de fond au large
de terre-neuve nouvelle fois l'épave du
titanic réveille nos fantasmes et les
convoitises
cette fois ci c'est une croisière qui
est organisée sur les lieux du naufrage
pour assister à la remontée d'une
nouvelle partie de l'ehpad et parmi les
invités de rescapés de la tragédie à
l'époque cette américaine avait 16 ans
son père a disparu dans le naufrage
comme celui de michel navratil un niçois
qui lui avait trois ans je suis venue
des arbres à new york depuis le naufrage
sur
rick est jamais ça n'a quitté la france
et sa fête a réussi toute ma vie c'était
un bateau merveilleux vraiment le plus
beau qui ait jamais existé
un paquebot merveilleux pourtant dépôt
s'est peu à peu depuis dix ans
aujourd'hui il s'agissait de récupérer
la paroisse de deux cabines de première
classe une nasse de 20 tonnes qu'il a
fallu d'abord extraire de la boue pour
mener à bien cette opération délicate
les américains ont fait appel au
spécialiste français de l'institut de
recherche de la mère liffré nerfs avec
l'aide du sous marin nautile 9 baudruche
géantes ont été accrochés ce matin ou
morcelée par eelv est rempli de gazole
plus léger que l'eau de mer les
baudruches devront faire remonter peu à
peu la paroisse du titanic à la surface
si tout va bien
on rentre au mans devrait coûter 25
millions de francs et ont rapporté
encore davantage
mais pour les rescapés du titanic
présent sur les lieux ce sera avant tout
un grand moment d'émotion